today we're gonna elaborate on and walk
expanders that four lad actually already
gave us gave us a taste of what these
objects are I'll redefine everything do
you simply due to the fact that I I
prefer a different notation than what he
gave and it will also give us a good
opportunity to like repeat these things
so I drew here my favorite example first
in palatial complex the fish complex and
I also drew like its facet diagram where
you actually draw a multi-part tight
graph right or a bunch of bipartite
graphs where the edges denote incidents
and and we remember that we had like a
process where we first choose sampled
one of these triangles in this case it
could be uniformly but it's gonna be in
any measure that we choose and then we
uniformly at random sample a path from
this triangle all the way down to the
empty set and this corresponds to from
the triangle choosing an edge uniformly
at random and then choosing a vertex
uniformly at random and then then
something trivial and it turns out that
this measured process actually actually
helps us to define two natural random
walks on K faces and the first random
walk is the upper walk where I go from k
face to K face my shirt k plus 1 face so
in this example I go for example from
edge to edge by a share triangle so my
process is if I'm at a particular edge I
choose a triangle that contained
and then from that triangle I trouve
uniformly at random another end so from
a JC I might Traverse to a DV or maybe a
GC or I might say an edge AC so this
just generalizes our walk from vertex to
vertex by assured edge right this is the
usual adjacency operator walk that we
already know but in in simplicial
complexes of a higher dimension we also
have the lower walk where I can go from
K 50k faced by assured K minus 1 face ok
by going through their intersection so
here given that I'm in some edge I first
choose one of its vertices ok which will
be the intersection and then I Traverse
to another edge that has its vertex and
might or might not you know might or
might not share a triangle with this
edge ok so we call these two walks the
upper walk ok we're given some TN
ex-king we first sample some s that
contains T and XK plus 1 and then
independently we sample
some P Prime and XK okay that is
contained in F and lore walk do the
exactly opposite given that we have some
T and X K we first sample so
intersection are in XK minus one that is
contained in T and then we sample the
prime that contains R again in X king so
for that called this one the up/down
walk and this one the down-up walk and
the reason he called it that is because
actually as we can see here we have like
two independent steps that correspond to
like two different perversions from an
edge i first pick a triangle this is to
traverse up and then from that triangle
i i go back to an edge or from an edge
to a vertex and from vertex back to that
edge and and as you could probably guess
as these are two independent steps I can
actually decompose the adjacency
operators of for this in this two like
bipartite adjacent the operators that
correspond to each of these individual
steps okay so these are the random walks
we defined yesterday and now I want to
talk about something new which is are
called the up and down operators
which are just bipartite adjacent
co-operators of each of these individual
steps
so in general when I have a bipartite
adjacency operator
I began from a function on one layer
here and then this operator actually
takes us either up to a function on the
next layer up or a function on the next
layer down so basically if I have a real
valued function on the K faces and I
look at f of F okay this will give me a
function okay on K plus-1 faces okay
this will be the up operator and how do
i define up of f on a k plus 1 face i
just do it by averaging so i take
expectation on other T's that contain s
and I look at f of T so example suppose
our function f gives the edge AC I don't
know minus one minus one maybe on all
these edges two in the middle and zero
on all the edges of this triangle so if
this is our F then what should be what
should be up f on the triangle say ABC
then we just go to this triangle we see
okay on AC it gives me minus one and a B
it gives me minus one and we see it
gives me two so it will just be minus
one minus one plus two over three so you
can ask yourself why am I using here the
uniform the uniform distribution to take
this expectation who said that I don't
have a different expectation and the
reason is that given a triangle
okay and when I take the next step to an
edge this is done with uniform
probability
so basically I can write here 1 over K +
2 sum of f of T so this have a nice
formula that doesn't depend on the
particular structure of the simplicial
complex be the down operator okay
given a function from K faces actually
gives me a function on K minus 1 faces
and it is defined in the same way if I
give it a K minus 1 face then it takes
expectation over all the K faces that
contain it and averages out and in this
case the averaging out might not be
uniform so for example if I look at C
over here namely we might expect that
because it's minus 1 2 and minus 1 we
might get 0 but actually as we saw as we
saw in the previous lecture this edge
since it contains it's contained in more
triangles then it has more weight and in
fact this is also true even if I
condition on this C so if I look at the
F in that example on the vertex C then
it will have like 2 times the
probability 1/2 minus 1 times 1/4 minus
1 times 1/4 where I'm taking these
probabilities over the conditional
probability of choosing the edge a C or
B C or D C given that I chose the vertex
C so it will be something else okay so
these are the up and down operators and
and a couple of comments the first one
is that these up and down operators are
a joint to one another so DK plus 1 is a
joint tuk in these inner products
and the second comment that I wanted to
give which is actually my main point is
that actually the Jason C operator for
the upper walk on K faces is just a
composition of first doing the ups by
step and then doing the step and the
lower walk is first doing the down step
and then doing the up step great so last
time okay yeah that's that's actually a
good comment historically I think that
people first looked at these these
operators in like an oriented version
and not phases but what was called
oriented phases and then they had then
they were accompanied with some
additional structure they were boundary
or boundary operators and here once we
lose the orientation we also lose this
additional structure and now we're just
looking at them as some averaging
bipartite averaging operators and and we
don't have this structure what is
yeah so that's an excellent question
because that was also my my second
comment that composing these operators
up and down they just correspond to
taking steps in this measure measured
process in different directions so if
I'm if I'm doing twice the up step then
I might go from it corresponds to the
two given B to correspond to just pick a
triangle that's that contains B and of
course I can do the down step at the
same time and in fact you know and any
any composition of the up and down steps
actually corresponds to some random walk
that gets me from I don't know from I
face to a K face depends on how much ups
and downs I I go okay so in fact once we
understand separately the up and the
down operators we can have the tools to
understand not only the upper and the
lower walk that we defined but also
about any walk you can think about that
you can pull you compose from them the
operators so UK will actually take you
down so the UK of F s will actually take
an average of four faces of a lower
dimension a lower dimension and and then
DK will look at kind of faces which you
get yeah seems to correspond to the
lower walk rather than the upper walk no
that's one UK seems to correspond to the
so let's take four let's take for
example first you apply UK and then
actually you first when you apply UK you
actually get a function that goes higher
right yeah and then when I apply DK I go
back lower so so like maybe let's look
at the example of a graph again okay we
did this yesterday but I think it's
useful to do this again
okay so um so if I'm looking at a de
Graaff okay so now KB equal zero okay
and we're looking just at an arbitrary
graph okay so what what I have a
function here the up step just given an
edge gives me an average of its two
vertices in the down step given a vertex
will average on this average and what we
will get from this okay is something
that will be something that would be
very similar to the adjacency operator
and in fact with probability with
probability 1/2 we will get the same we
will get to the same place and with
probability 1/2 we will just reverse as
the usual graph operator okay and this
corresponds to the fact that because I'm
doing these steps independently then I
have a probability of 1/2 to the
probability of have to stay in place
okay the operator okay which is first to
down and then do up in the vertex case
so what could it be I mean this operator
factors through one dimensional space of
functions right so this this actually if
the projection to the constant functions
so you see the directions must be in
this way because the down operator
indeed projects me down to the constants
which which corresponds to the lower
stuff yeah that's maybe it gets you need
to get used to the notation some point I
can to convince myself this the walk is
opposite of what the operators is like
so because this thing has a probability
of have to stay in place okay it's given
given a specific function on the vertex
the the output of the upper walk relies
heavily on the value of the initial the
the initial vertex then these walks
again they want to be they won't be
similar at least when the number of
vertices goes to infinity and then here
the probability of laziness will be very
small
however we discussed this last time that
that in fact if we look at the
difference between the the non lazy
adjacency operator and the lower walk
okay then in operator norm this is
exactly the two-sided spectral expand
expand a expansion parameter at the
graph G okay this will be the second the
second eigenvalue of the adjacency
operator okay so we can't say the upper
walk and the lower walk are similar here
due to the laziness but if we look at
the non lazy not lazy part of the upper
walk then then in certain cases
we can say that it's similar at least
spectrally to the to the lower walk and
when did this happen precisely when when
G is an expander graph okay so so in
general we would like to say that our
definition to high dimensional expanders
encapsulate the same idea so
so in general okay up down okay or the
upper walk from on K face it's the K
faces it has a laziness that goes down
with K but is still a constant that
depends only on the dimension and not in
the specific structure of our simplicial
complex so for example for an edge what
it doesn't matter to which triangle I go
up to the probability to stay in the
same edge is one-third right because
it's the one over the number of edges
inside a triangle so in general we can
decompose this operator to 1 over k plus
2 which with the probability to stay in
place plus k plus 1 over k plus 2 let's
call it m of k where m of cave that non
lazy
our walk okay so M of K I don't take two
steps independently i go from k face to
K face where I also demand that the face
is TN T prime here will will be
different from each other
okay and we define X a d-dimensional
simplicial complex to be a lambda random
walk high dimensional expander okay if
not lazy upper walk minus the lower walk
less or equal to lambda
whenever case probably properly defined
here okay so what does this mean this
means that I define a random walk
expander precisely when going through
the upper walk and going through the non
sorry going through the gnarly the upper
walking going through the lower walk are
similar again at least in a spectral
this in a spectral sense
so obviously one motivation for this
definition is that it may be generalizes
generalizes our definition of spectral
expander in the graph another may be
motivation to this definition is that
the definition that meaning it discussed
last time that dealt with the links was
very local in nature I mean we maybe
don't precisely understand you know if
every link of say here a vertex is an
expander and the underlying graph is an
expander most of these conditions are
very local and maybe we don't understand
so well from these conditions what is
the global behavior and this gives like
a much more compact and global global
definition and and I think one question
that comes into mind is what is the
relation between random walk expanders
and the definition of high dimensional
expanders due to due to the spectral
expansions of the link so so in fact is
poor allowed they also discussed this
yesterday we have a theorem work with
elite evil famous and of course / Lud
that these two notions of of expansion
are essentially equivalent at least when
lambda is very small so in fact if X
lambda 2 sided high dimensional link
expander the way we defined yesterday
this implies that X is a lambda a random
walk high dimensional expander and and
the other way around if X is a
d-dimensional lambda random walk high
dimensional expander then X is not
exactly lambda but lambda times a
constant that depends only on the
dimension two sided high dimensional
link
so what is the high dimensional ink
expander I think yesterday we call this
the high dimensional spectral expander
so sorry for the double terminology in
any case I want to emphasize that this
definition looks at a spectral expansion
of the links while this definition is
our new one so let's like spend the next
five or 10 minutes actually to actually
discuss why this is true yes the links
and and the link of the empty set which
is the one skeleton of the whole the
whole simplicial complex both of these
statements are tight so this is
definitely not tight even for the
the top of my head I don't know so for
the first item why is this true let's
look at it this way if I'm I want to
show that the upper walk is similar to
the lower walk and what does it mean
that lambda is a two-sided spectral
expander or link expander it means that
given that I chose the vertex I'm going
through okay
the lower walk is just choosing two
edges independently but given that I'm
in the world that I contain this vertex
okay but given this vertex if I choose
the upper walk then going from an edge
to an end okay here which corresponds to
going through a shared triangle that
again already color corresponds to this
vertex is just the same as going from a
vertex to a vertex in the link of this
intersection okay through a shared edge
so if we know that in every link we are
a two-sided Heidemann high-dimensional
link expander then these works locally
and every link should be similar and
through garlands method we will get that
this is actually singular globally so
let's let's write this down baby and you
see that at least item 1 is like really
repeating the idea that we also saw
yesterday so what do I need to prove I
need to show right I need to show that
MK minus udy is less or equal to lambda
in spectral norm and essentially this
means that I need to show that a
supermoon over m k minus udy with itself
is equal to lambda oh yes of course
for
thank you and how do I do this so let's
try to calculate M K of F with itself so
this is an adjacency operator from case
to case so as we saw yesterday it
corresponds to just choosing an edge in
the upper walk which in our case is just
choosing choosing two K faces that have
a shirt k plus 1 face and averaging the
expression F of T F of T Prime
so you know that it won't hurt for us to
think of K is 1 okay so we're looking
maybe at the edges the edge upper Walker
so now I want to use the garland method
on on this expression okay so how do I
sample these ta T's and T Prime's so one
way to describe it if the first we
sample s that is in X clay K plus 1
which is might be a triangle and then we
take TN T Prime inside of us that are
different from one another so I can look
at this expression and
and now to use Garland's method just
similar to what we did yesterday
let's condition this on the intersection
of T and T Prime
so first let's choose a vertex V in the
intersection of T and T prime okay then
we choose a triangle F that's contained
in that contains V right it will be like
s will be equal to V u in W and then I
output T which will be V U and T prime
which will be the W right so doing this
is the same as doing this but now what
do I see again if I take a triangle
given that it contains me it's precisely
equivalent choosing UW as an edge in the
link of V right so what I have here is
expectation over the expectation over UW
as an edge in the link of V F of V U V W
so if I denote maybe F superscript V of
you to be F of view like this then what
we actually get is a similar garland
expression you see this expectation over
V of the inner product in the link
okay so I'll write it all right it's
here maybe what I might need the diagram
the fish itself is
you don't need the fish but we like it
so what I wanted to say is that taking
expectation over V we're just looking at
the expression of a VF superscript to be
inner product with F superscript V right
this is exactly what happens when I do
the adjacency operator and F superscript
V and inner product it with itself
inside the link good so now again we
repeat the steps that we did yesterday
and we can write F superscript V of some
to be some better V times the local
constant function plus F superscript V
perp right and then what we get here is
that this is an expectation over V of
like this weight of e squared plus
expectation over V of a VF V perp as
weeper okay so let's not do all that
Gaborik steps again but in general due
to the fact that the jason see the
adjacency operator of the local vertices
is a very good is a two-sided spectral
expander this is like this this is
killed by it this is will be equal less
or equal to lambda also in in absolute
value
okay and then all we need to do again is
to calculate what is better V is okay if
I look at this better way
what is this better be it's just an
average overall the use in the link of V
of F superscript vu which is the same of
averaging all the edges that contains V
view so what is the average on all the
edges that contain V F of this thing
this is just the down operator operating
on F at vertex V so what we can say is
that expectation of beta V squared is
just equal to the inner product of DF DF
and as we said before the joint of of
the F of D is u so this is just up down
F with itself so what what we're getting
here in essence is that if I take em k
FF
and it's abstract this expression then
what remains is something that is less
than lambda in absolute norm so again
this is like the ideas are very similar
to what we saw yesterday I look at some
mysterious operator I try to decompose
it via the local structure and what we
call garland's method and and then all I
need to figure out is what meaning does
the what meaning that the constant part
in this decomposition means so in this
case it's just the it's just the down
operator this is like one item for item
two I don't think I want to do the full
proof but let me maybe just sketch what
the main idea is so an item two I know
that globally the up and down operators
the difference is less than lambda in
spectral norm and you would maybe expect
that because this thing is global and
every link looks at just a little
portion of this walked and maybe I don't
know maybe you know one link could be
bad and all the rest could be maybe very
good and still globally it would average
out to be a pretty good a pretty good
random walk however notice that if I
have like a link of say of vertex and I
and I like realize this link in this
diagram right then I can view this link
right and all the edges
I can view this link as just looking at
all the edges that are contained in V
and the work in the link is just the
work in the triangle given that I'm
contained in V so if I have like an
eigen an eigen vector of the local
adjacency operator right I can write it
down here right this will be F of U of U
F of W etc etc and sorry yeah and I'm
trying to show that the eigen the local
eigen vectors of the link must also
correspond to small eigen values yes the
rich link is a good expander thank you
so just to repeat again one what I want
to do so I want to take an eigen vector
of some eigen value of the local link
and then the main idea is just that I
can globalize it and simply looking at
this as a global vector where for every
vertex that or for every edge that does
not correspond to a vertex in the link
of V ie that it does not contain me I
just put here all zeros and if you do
the calculation then from here it's
almost all calculations to see that the
eigen the local eigen value must be must
be small because this difference will be
small and somehow this difference if I
look at it over this grove of this
global function all its weight is like
concentrated inside
so so we get like three k plus one
constant that's that that's what also
appears in the fear of my thing yeah so
it's not because some induction it's
some internal computation in the proof I
think the point is you have your
approximating each of these local random
box with a lambda I matrix now when you
add them out these local random walks or
and every location K up there will be
added up because they don't pay that
because each other you know this is what
they do those calculations in this is a
calculation with just three all of the I
n minus two equal to lambda
approximately from the I and then there
is no cancellation so they can you can
get K copies add it up at the CEO should
also say that if K somehow somehow also
relates to the laziness or the inverse
probability probability like here when
we need to calculate the down operator
then we look at some ladies here and it
somehow ruins our constant
to tell you the truth I'm not sure that
this is I'm not sure that this is tight
I mean it might be an artifact of the
truth and in fact we can get something
wrong something better maybe
the last portion of my talk I would like
to show maybe the advantages in this
definition in decomposing decomposing
functions and K faces in some natural
way
so it turns out that these up and down
steps or these up and down operators
actually give us a natural way to
correspond to sorry to decompose real
valued functions on K faces so for
example if we have just functions on
vertices of a graph okay then we use
this decomposition again and again I can
always decompose them to their constant
part and the part that's perpendicular
to the constant part so one way to look
at this composition is to say okay the
constant part is a function that came
actually from the empty set by using
this up operator somehow and the part
that's perpendicular to the constant
part it couldn't have come from below so
it must have came from the first level
and in general okay in general we would
like to somehow decompose now if we take
an F from a general XK we would somehow
like to decompose this F as functions
that correspond to maybe functions that
came from different lower levels of the
simplicial complex so for those of you
who are maybe reminded by this this
maybe might resemble a bit the
decomposition that we have in the
boolean hypercube where we can decompose
real valued functions on the boolean
hypercube to their parts according to
some characters and in these characters
we can like somehow naturally partition
them to characters that come from
different set sizes so in high dimension
and expanders in general we have much
less structure than the boolean
hypercube so I guess you know it might
be too naive to expect that we have like
characters that are homomorphic
and they you know behave well under
multiplication and a lot of like good
things that maybe come from the vector
space structure or group structure
however in high dimensional expanders we
do have maybe an approximation of some
of these properties in a decomposition
so first of all what do I mean by
functions that are that come from a
level a lower level so what do I mean by
this F to J's so one guess one guests of
something that should be a natural
example of a function that comes from a
level J is just it's just if F or maybe
not officially but a function that might
have came from the level J is just the
indicator of maybe all the asses that
contains some fixed T zero in X J so for
example if we if we look at J equals one
then we can look at want to be all the
SS that contain maybe a specific edge UV
okay so why do we look at this is like a
function yeah so thank you for that I'm
saying one example is this function and
I can of course maybe if I wanted to say
that if was a decomposition then I would
probably want to say that F that comes
from the level J should be maybe a
linear combination of these these
functions but maybe just one step before
that I mean why do we even perceive this
function as a function that comes from
the level J so I can think of two
reasons the first reason which is like a
purely combinatorial reason
it is that the output depends only on J
vertices all right so here the output
and s only depends if s contains these
two if two vertices or not and another
another maybe intuition that maybe this
is indicator it actually comes from a
function on the edge on the edge set
okay that's the indicator of the set UV
itself after we done we've done a lot of
up operators on it taking it from the
edge set to the triangle set all the way
up to K okay maybe I'll abbreviate this
by U of 1 to K okay this is not exactly
an equality but if I multiply here by
some scalar that is due to the fact that
we're actually averaging enough summing
up then then this is this is true so the
first property is the first property of
maybe combinatorial and it's not too
apparent on how we generalize this
however the second property right maybe
we would just want to say that J level
functions
should be like be like functions on the
J's level that we lifted up from J to K
so this is like a naive attempt to
define J level functions or one level
functions etc however one I think
natural problem arises suppose I have a
function that I lifted from the edges to
the triangle so I want to think about it
as level two function
but who told how do I know that this
function that was on the edges maybe
actually it had a component that came
from the vertices right so it's a level
two function is the level one function
is to have a zero function so so this
definition is somehow not good enough
but but the way we solve it okay and
this is the actual definition that we
need a J level function up from J to K
of some function HJ okay where H J does
not contain a component that came from
from below so actually that is
perpendicular to all the up 3-1 of G's
okay this means it's less perpendicular
to the image of you J minus 1 and like
from this reminds very much only the
homological things right like this seems
to be inspired by these kinds of right
things that comes from below so yeah you
can say that maybe it's
you can say that maybe it's inspired by
this but here I mean there's no qualms
erotic commodity right because I do two
times up I don't get yes you will stick
to functions that are actually like but
everything that came from below itself
like defined how it works for the vertex
level so you can do it at the edges by
just doing one off and then that gives
you three possibilities then you do
nothing happen another three and one
extra perpendicular one so you can keep
doing that right yes yes not only that
we can that's what we actually do just
to finish my sentence here this is just
equivalent being perpendicular to the
toward the image of up is just
equivalent to being in the kernel of
down so we actually have a way to check
that were perpendicular to other image
of Earth and like you said our actual
decomposition actual decomposition okay
so our F will be equal to some F J goes
from minus one to K F equals J or f
equal J is a function on the jet level
that is in the kernel of the down
operator or equivalent equivalently is
perpendicular to the to its own up
operator so we take this function in
just lift it up and what you said is
correct I mean once I know this
decomposition is true for the vertex
level which is proof from trivial
reasons I can immediately by induction
get this composition to the I don't want
to do it here but but that's all there
is to it so we call this yes that's a
great question so we call this a
decomposition but in fact
it's not it's not a unique decomposition
or it doesn't have to be a unique
decomposition all the time and in fact
you know suppose that for the up
operator we don't it kernel is not
trivial there's some vector in the
kernel then this means that I could
write zero right using two types of HJs
for example so in fact it's an if and
only if but in general this
decomposition doesn't have to be unique
and it might not have may be orthogonal
I'm saying that these h JS apply only if
the view of this composed up operator is
not empty right then I can write 0
either as UJ 2 K of 0 or UJ 2 K of some
other vector in the that I see so when I
when when when I said unique I meant
that I meant that if H J's are
necessarily different that's why this
decomposition is is not unique so just
maybe because of like I dimension a
dimension argument where here we have
like dimension 3 space of functions and
it may be couldn't have come from
unique by the construction like you take
it if you look at everything that comes
from below that's some subspace of all
possible functions FK is just okay right
FK is just something in the kernel of
this and it's orthogonal to everything
that comes from below but let's look at
F K minus one so initially HK minus one
were right it was orthogonal to do
everything that everything that came
from below however this might be
orthogonal but but now I'm doing you to
this and and used to listen they might
not be orthogonal anymore right if maybe
the kernel is not empty they must might
both collapse to the same thing
okay so so this is not necessarily true
anymore
however what
what what what is true and this is also
this is also a theorem that if X Y D
dimension lambda random walk expander
lambda small enough compared to the
dimension then this is a a unique
decomposition okay
furthermore from being unique this is an
almost this is an almost orthogonal
decomposition okay so in general maybe
this view does not maintain
orthogonality but we will get maybe an
error here that depends on lambda and of
course the norms of the of these
functions which which has to be because
if we multiply this by scalar this
growth and and the third maybe maybe
most surprising thing here is that these
f JS if I perform the up operator on
them then these things are approximately
eigenvectors with eigenvalue that depend
only on the level of the simplicial
complex and when i mean approximately
here again i mean up to an error that
depends only on lambda and and of course
the size of f j itself so what we get in
a high dimensional expander that this
decomposition is a decomposition of
approximate eigen values eigen vectors
okay so they're not exactly a scalar
multiple but they're very close to it
and because this is like a symmetrical
form if they correspond to approximate
different eigen values then they would
be approximately
orthogonal and this of course implies
when this error is small enough this of
course implies that the decomposition
must be also unique so I don't think
we'll prove this now because the proof
is maybe with a lot of science but in
essence maybe I'll just say that the
proof somehow uses the fact that the up
operator is some constant times the
identity plus something that looks
approximately like the down operator
plus maybe some error so somehow if I
use the up operator it's just like
multiplying by scalar and using the down
operator so somehow I can use like a
recursive argument here to use the down
operator on these things and then use it
on lower levels
[Applause]
representative w2 in three holes and
make another conditional manner
no no no this is all three results
oh yeah yeah
more questions okay then